luego de asolar el centro de europa
ahora hacen estragos de limpia turquía
china y japón- estas imágenes son de una
ciudad turca devastada por las
inundaciones más al este en china e
intensas lluvias azotan las regiones del
suroeste el país vive su segunda
catástrofe después de que unas
precipitaciones récord se cobraron la
vida de más de 300 personas del mes
pasado
en japon partes de la isla sureña de
kyushu registraron el sábado niveles
récord de lluvia que inundaron las
calles y provocaron deslizamientos de
tierra los científicos no descartan que
la crisis climática esté acelerando
estos fenómenos meteorológicos extremos
el cambio climático provoca una
atmósfera cálida que retiene más agua lo
que aumenta el riesgo y la intensidad de
las precipitaciones extremas según el
ipcc la autoridad científica
internacional de referencia sobre el
clima lo que no deja lugar a dudas es la
mano del hombre en el calentamiento
global los expertos lo señalaron en su
último informe publicado el lunes 9 de
agosto
los incendios forestales fuera de
control en grecia y turquía los domos de
calor en california y en canadá los
incendios forestales fuera de control en
siberia las inundaciones en alemania y
china basta con mirar a cualquier parte
del mundo para ver cómo se presenta la
catástrofe climática
lo que hace es informe es explicar lo
que está pasando por la ciencia diciendo
que ahora estamos seguros de que todo
esto se debe a la actividad humana sainz
jr gwyneth en ese sentido el destino del
planeta está ahora en manos de los
políticos y de su consenso para acelerar
medidas que bajen los impactos del
calentamiento global